North Korea is threatening to test the
most powerful hydrogen bomb into the
Pacific Ocean
Yong Yong's foreign minister made the
threat after President Trump announced
new financial sanctions against the
north the country's supreme leader
that's Kim jong-un also responded
directly to the president's warning that
he will totally destroy North Korea if
necessary to protect the US and its
allies
well Kim said this in a statement quote
I will surely and definitely tame the
mentally deranged u.s. dotard with fire
and in case you were wondering the word
dotard used in North Korea's translation
means a weak or senile old person Ben
Tracy is in Beijing with Kim's
unprecedented attack and Ben this war of
words is getting nasty good morning so
this is the statement released by North
Korea on Friday morning and is unusual
for two reasons one this is from Kim
jong-un himself it's not from North
Korean state media secondly it is highly
personal and highly critical of
President Trump now in this statement
kim jeong-hoon calls the President of
the United States mentally deranged a
rogue and a gangster fond of playing
with fire and says that a frightened dog
barks louder now Kim jong-un appears to
be very upset by president Trump's
speech to the United Nations this week
in which he called the North Korean
leader rocket man on a suicide mission
and threatened to totally destroy North
Korea if the u.s. is forced to defend
its allies or itself now in response Kim
Jong moon said president Trump's remarks
have convinced me rather than
frightening or stopping me that the path
I chose is correct and that it is the
one I have to follow to the last now the
path he is talking about of course is
North Korea's unrelenting march towards
possessing nuclear weapons capable of
hitting the United States
gaile all right thank you Ben Tracy